I know you're all going to roll your
eyes at me you're going to say Michael
enough Christy posting enough talking
about the chrysosons which some of us
who think Christy has something of a
shot to have a role in the race we're
calling it the croissants I'm just
telling you Christy is apparently set to
announce his run and I'm not saying he's
going to be the nominee don't I'm not
saying he should be the nominee I'm just
telling you guys I give you hard truths
okay I don't Pander to you I calls him
like I sees him and here's what I'm
telling you there is a non-zero chance
that Chris Christie has a moment in this
race here's why the reason why is all
the reasons that you're rolling your
eyes it's all the reasons that you're
screaming and wailing and rending your
garments right now no I don't want to
talk about Chris Christie that's why
Chris Christie has the worst qualities
of all the candidates which oddly makes
him kind of a good candidate